AJA HAMMERLY: In
this Cloud Minute,
I'll show you how Stackdriver
Logging's exclusion filters let
you control what and
how much you log.
From the web UI, click Logging,
and then click Resource Usage.
The top of the page shows
you your current usage
and what your projected logs
usage for this month is.
I can disable all the logs
for a specific product
by clicking here.
I can also exclude only messages
that match a specific pattern
by clicking Create Exclusion.
Once I click, I'm redirected
to the logs viewer,
and I can search for
the specific messages
I want to exclude.
I want to exclude
all the Stackdriver
monitoring uptime checks.
I do my search, and it shows
me the matching log messages.
Once I've created a filter
that works, I put in a name
for the exclusion
filter, and then I
can decide what percentage
of these messages
should be excluded.
In this case, I want 100%.
Now I click Create
Exclusion, and messages
that match my filter won't
appear in the log viewer.
But I can export
them, if needed.
I hope this helps you make
efficient use of Stackdriver
Logging.